salut tout le monde est bienvenu pour
cette nouvelle vidéo ça lui va bien
salut qu est ce que vous donc on regarde
aujourd'hui fab la partie qui a opposé
magnus carlsen anish giri exactement
beaucoup de vide ça à louvain est donc
un système long c'est parti avec le f5
donc on a déjà vu j'entre dans les
partys magnus oui jouer que ces quatre
et se laisse prendre un bain que laisse
prendre les chèques en d4 du coup le
stade pas de pièce pour interpréter des
rockets mais c'est pas si grave
sarkissian jeune mc 4 c'est le coup
recommandé par la théorie mais vont bien
évidemment où je vous donne d'autres
coûts qui sont très récents on est trois
venus des trois trous de kebede 2h 3,6
kg kkb ie5 villa aimerait bien tiens à
droite il le fait de manière un peu
j'apprends que je vois cette position
tous les systèmes donc tout le temps je
ne me rappelle plus non mais il a lui
même joué qu'à tout le temps veut pas à
3 ça ne sert à rien ça te redonne le
très bas moins il veut plus qu'il soit
retrouvé 4
donc là et les drames j'imagine que
c'est ici ce qui va très bien peut-être
ces cinq cavaliers 4
qui sait si ce par contre elle m'a pas
trop tu vois on n'aime pas bloquer notre
tour c'est par la tv line
j'avais très mal placée dans celle du
pion dame et puis on prend un coup qu'on
n'est pas mentionné c'est pourquoi
j'aurais vraiment à fait dans le sens
même jour paraissait simple non mais ça
va en fait mais j'aime pas trop prononcé
quatre enfants aurait fait même si tu
préfères qu'il bougeait une fois gagné
le temps et tout ça tu as tout compris
très malin les basiques g3 est donc
souvent on dit que c'est peut-être
dangereux de prendre en g3 ton club
lombard ok car ou la colonne âge
après cette vente ou le chou des gens à
f/5 je pense que ce n'est pas trop de
danger pendant pour les marques
d'ailleurs car le rock et ne cherche pas
utiliser ce que le match mais ça
pourrait être un poil hamas il faut plus
attendre des 3t décaler les cinq des
trucs pas prendre automatiquement g3a
plus en plus ou moins égales et blanc
comme un microscopique avantage ouais
mais ça ressemble à des positions un peu
de grands vides à m'accepter on va dire
la structure mais le foot pièce blanche
n'a pas trop l'habitude de le voir
devant la chaîne de pions te voir toi tu
as vu il sera d'abord ans et 8 ou death
is to b 7
donc ça change qui peut l'inter de la
position mais
un niveau structure tout ça c'est je
pense qu'il faut prendre d'une pièce on
avec le pian sparkom dangereux fab ont
lu cavaliers c'est pas un truc logique
tête de la dame sait pas si mal je
parraine la dame quand même leur après
tu m'as tatum en d1 et essaye de mode
tricoter ouais
ouais tu tricote
mais magnus j'arrive un peu désabusé
dans cette partie le dos et 100 kg a pas
envie de jouer cette partie comme si
l'attitude mois après vente usa c'est un
truc qui va arriver se fait dessus ça
fout là mais tu le sens tu sens qu'il
est par moment où il a joué à troyes
tous on donne sous le joug des
particules ok tout rester un bon retour
au centre une femme non pas du tout 6
affiche enfin honnêtement je comprends
pas trop j'ai fait tous rêvent dé 8 3
puis 3 g77
si tu vas pas maman le il veut quoi il
veut sur carré lieu le 5 à la fois f5 et
sur g4 parfois je souhaite avec une
simple paire de son jeu de foot quoi non
expliqué un truc bon c'est bon pas de
jouer à 6 à lui beaucoup groupe avait
dit cool en attaque à 7 et le quéré
venir éventuellement donc trouvons des
six j'avais pensé être franc c'est un tu
donnes la colonne marqué pas mal joué
sur ces 8 sur torrent et à kalima la
défense à tout va ça c'est plutôt bien
joué
maroc est un peu on peut prendre et si
faire une petit nul 20-20 toujours fait
une partie sans grand intérêt à ce
moment là bas les bombes à la vague n'a
joué à troyes non je voulais finale du
c1 est complètement égal
pour l'instant je vous entends très
insipide comme party by mickey maintien
des gaves j'aime et de cahiers à 8,5 et
p 500 vols toutes les cases recettes
peut-être quand même non je fais une
dispute interne une bombe à 6 non plus
tu n'as pas leur a d'ailleurs écrit j'ai
arraché interdite non j'ai pas compris
un mari voulait pas être servis si par
g4 c'est un grand mot mais d'autres
puits qui fixe d'ailleurs le plongeon
non heureusement ce que ma vie j'ai
l'air complètement dégoûté de toute la
partie propose même panier
je suis dégouté je vais je vais te
battre qu'on attendait goûter une finale
il ya ben ouais ça fait super chedjou et
cette partie mais bon je l'a bien
cherché
mais qui sont côte à côte yonne c'est
marrant parce qu'en même bouteille sont
côte à côte qui contrôlent book n'est
toutefois nos barrières pareil de corail
peuvent pas les rails d'orange et plus
on paye et tout plein de corail beaucoup
de corail dans cette partie du relais
saint jacques sont corail au mieux
comprendre sa réaction quand même en
partant là ouais brême c'est que ton
corail après qu'un essai 5 cm remettre
un message à que bretonne du tout son
sens à l'horizon paraît très fiers
photos de wiimote sarac est meilleur il
n'y a pas de corail bas derrière qui a
aidé un bond record par à contresens
contre-courant je suis un saumon a été
sous mon intégration dans ce moment
astrologie de chemnitz
non c'est l'aspect régis et s'est arrogé
papa tu tire une carte et tu vas tu
attends un mail totems sont pas si elle
émane total d'un saumon légal qui nagent
à contre-courant je suis ascendant
jack les cousines
je sais pas ce que fait ma minute il
partit complètement insipide mais bon on
va voir s'ils arrivent à s'en sortir
enfin s'en sortir oui sans doute mais
via nîmes
pareil chez tf6 je fais payer ces singes
échange de gavanon mais je ne vois pas
trop ça se voit que ça fait super g
depuis le début 1 1
en fait ils jouent contre en plus dire
il annula tu ne peux pas te dis mais
cette finale par plaisir non mais doc et
mathieu roy des deux cas et c'est ça qui
prend prendre ces trois études tu tends
la main que tu donnes ta pince mais bon
c'est un consommateur
ouais alésienne des parties beaucoup
plus intéressante finalement j'ai
peut-être même faire être proche 5
pourrait changer car des pièces on va
augmenter l'intérêt de cette partie
bayahi réfléchit non mais après au
québec gagne son bonne partie de l'année
noire il joue solide il tient pour
l'instant très bien qu'on m'accuse rien
à lui reprocher quoi parle à personne
nous faut toute une partie et ça arrive
ça arrive fréquemment
mais je ne sais même pas qui c'est de
jouer en fait à olemps ça change pas
grand chose mais je passe
le csac même si je checke et ordonne le
train c'est un relance et on s'écarte
maintenant ok quelque part logique mais
on peut très bien fait juste pessah
voilà ce jour demandé ce qu'on fait b 5
heures sont ici peut-être doha notre
cliente détroit ensuite pour venir
verser 5 b 4 je sais pas quoi mais j'ai
fait des essais 5 mais oui je vous
prends très bien mais bon et b2 en face
à celui des semailles les hits quand
même les hits
non ça bout
vincent je sens que pas mal de gens
maintenant temps de magnus comprennent
qu'il faut penser le plonger deux
casques way and milk guérini mode
bitstream et un autre à charge avait
fait ça en double gifle je me gratte les
cheveux fans de coûts mais chez moi je
fais trois ses droits ce soir a dit que
faire cavalier callas sûrement pas trop
les soucis de la position mais bon des
fois quand tu joues en pratique tu vois
plein déjà plus de trucs que nous c'est
sûr qu'il y va de base tu te poses des
trucs des machins aux prétentions le
truc là esneu part et c'est comme ça que
tu perds aussi maintenant parce que tu
vois ça peut être une question tout et
villareal soit qu'on est pas si vous la
forcez vite et tu évites plus important
tu tu évites toi mais les vang et 6 4
mais on va peut-être venir vers eux 3 f
en fait je sais pas si c'est pas auto a
publié par ckoi d'entreprendre duquel du
cavalier fin et tempo du cavaliere mais
tu vois il est trop petit enfin moi
j'étais un pro du kavé mais voilà nul ah
oui on m'a enfermée
oui h4 ainsi on prend le pas de calais
fairway 3g 3 et mac os que ça se calcule
pas si grave bon ok pas se présenter
plus les inrocks et tu veux tu être
soulignée par la force ont alors envahi
la ville à fermer
num dirige val d'or moi j'étais guérie
cgt joue h 4 bonne partie